earlier today
president trump vetoed the national
defense authorization act
the ndaa following through on his
promise to veto the bill if congress
didn't strip away
liability protections for big tech and
also calling the legislation a gift to
u.s adversaries
china and russia and we're also learning
more tonight about the massive
solar winds cyber hack on multiple
federal
agencies also tonight the rogue iranian
regime
is continuing to fuel violence and stoke
tensions
across the middle east prompting
president trump to tweet earlier today
our embassy in baghdad got hit sunday by
several rockets
three rockets failed to launch guess
where they were from
iran now we hear chatter of additional
attacks
against americans in iraq some friendly
healthy advice to iran
if one american is killed i will hold
iran responsible
think it over joining me now for insight
on all of this
national security advisor ambassador
robert o'brien
ambassador thank you so much for joining
us i want to go first to our ron give us
the latest on that situation
well jason great to be with you and by
the way congratulations on your byu
cougars and their big win last night
uh i know you were following that uh the
whole season closely so
yes that was good so listen the
situation iran is
in iraq is no different than has been
for many many years the
iraq the iranian regime is uh trying to
drive the united states uh out of our
uh our our alliances out of our
partnerships and our
position in the middle east with our
friends and allies there uh they're
using proxies to do it in
in iraq they're using kativ hezbollah
and other shia militia groups
and and they've executed attacks against
the embassy and other american
facilities and the president
made it very clear that if an american
is killed uh that's a red line for us
and iran is gonna we'll be
we'll bear the responsibility for it and
i think he sent a very strong message
today and if i was the iranians i would
heed that message he's uh
he remains the president he's gonna be
the president until at least january
20th
and uh and they would be uh i think
it'll be foolish of iran to uh
to test his uh his will on this issue
i i gotta move on to the hack or the
attack on our federal government
via computer i think there's been a
cyber war going on for years
who was it who's responsible and what
can the united states do to fight back
on this
well we're undertaking a massive
investigation of the incident
it's clearly a sophisticated
intelligence operation and
no doubt was done by a state actor and
we'll get around to attribution of that
at a time and place of our choosing
we're mitigating the the problem and
we're making sure that our networks are
safe and uh
and that the uh the malware and
uh and the back doors are being closed
and uh and thrown out of the systems and
by the way during this christmas season
i want to thank the uh the frontline
workers on this in the cyber war the
folks from the fbi the dni
nsa dhs from my uh national security
council team
that have a little bit literally been
working around the clock since this
breach was discovered to keep us safe to
protect our networks and to
expel the malicious uh software and code
that that it's
that's now in the system so they're
doing a great job while we're
celebrating the holidays they're working
24 7 to uh
to keep us safe and i want to pass on
the presence thanks to them and my
thanks as well
yeah i know i studied this when i was in
congress and the united states is
constantly under attack and it's very
hard to get the talent that we need in
order to protect against
those threats but everything from a guy
in a van down by the river to these
nation states coming after us
um i i want to move though we got to hit
a lot of subjects
the national defense authorization act
the president threatened that he'd veto
it but he actually did it today
why did he do it what does he want to
see changed in order to get it signed
well the one thing i want to make clear
is that when the president took office
he inherited the military that the
readiness was the worst in uh probably
in american history at least since the
second world war
we were out of ammunition we had the
lowest ship count ever
the the military had suffered through
eight years of sequestration under the
uh
obama administration he turned that
around and spent over two and a half
trillion dollars rebuilding our military
we now have the greatest fighting force
in the world he's also taking care of
our veterans in a way that
has never happened before so the
president's been totally committed to a
strong national defense
the ronald reagan idea of peace through
strength this bill unfortunately didn't
include the protections that were
necessary
with section 230 the communications
decency act
which our adversaries are using to
promote disinformation on twitter and
facebook and other social media
platforms
we've got to get that reformed to
protect the american people
number two the president campaigned on
ending forever wars and
he's drawn down troops in afghanistan
and iraq to 2500
in both places and we can redeploy those
troops to the front lines and in eastern
europe and the indo-pacific
to protect american interests and uh and
and protect us from our great power
adversaries the same ones that
that are have had us under attack uh
cyber and otherwise for many many years
and this this bill purports to uh to
take away his constitutional rights as
commander-in-chief
to deploy our armed forces and the same
goes with germany where we want to move
troops
out of these big fixed bases and put
them into our front-line positions to
deter our adversaries and protect our
friends
so so it was constitutionally suspect
and
and lastly it gets into culture wars
that really shouldn't be debated
there may be a legitimate debate there
but they shouldn't be debated and the
military shouldn't be held hostage
uh with the ndaa so the president didn't
think it was the right bill to sign at
this time
he wants a strong defense he's just
submitted a 355-ship
navy shipbuilding plan that's terrific
and is paid for for many many years
uh in part because we're drawing down
and ending and wrapping up some of these
forever wars
uh so he's got a great record on defense
he's proud of it he wants a clean bill
to come back from
from the congress as soon as possible
one that he can sign
yeah and listen nobody will cheer him on
more than myself in terms of bringing
our troops home
from these endless wars uh we all we we
ought to celebrate bringing our troops
home it's amazing to me how many people
just want them to stay there in
perpetuity i think the president
is listening to the american people and
wants to bring those troops home and
needs the flexibility as the president
to do so
uh i gotta end though on china uh donald
trump has done more
from my vantage point to push back and
highlight china and
and look at what they're doing on so
many fronts
walk us through what the president's
been able to do in china i've only got
about 40 seconds
i'll be quick they hollowed out our
manufacturing by stealing our
intellectual property and and
subsidizing their their
state-owned enterprises and and buying
our our manufacturing facilities and
moving them lock stock and barrel to
china the president put on tariffs and
stop
that got a great phase one trade deal
they've extinguished freedom in hong
kong and the president's made him pay a
price for that
uh they're they're engaged in in
terrible activities in sinjar with the
uyghurs and
and destroying religious freedom they've
attacked our friends in india on the
border they've taken over the entire
south china sea and claimed that sarah's
like it's a some sort of domestic lake
like a lake tahoe
and we've stood up to them and we've
stood up to them across the board huawei
was taking over the world with 5g
so that the chinese communist party
could control all of our data
the president stopped that and now most
of our allies are going to have clean
networks and
are expelling huawei from their 5g
networks and we're going to have data
privacy
and protect our national security so
what he's done on china he's shown that
we can win i think there were a lot of
defeatists who believe we could never
stand up to china
the president and the american people
showed we could compete with china and
we can win
ambassador robert o'brien many thanks to
you and your family you
work exceptionally hard as does your
staff
pour in your heart and soul into it
thank you for your service may god bless
you and
have a very merry christmas merry
christmas jason thank you